can I regret this yes okay
sometimes when you're under quarantine
and we have nothing to do you know what
the problem is my hair if I get rid of
my hair I'll have time to think about
other things so right now on the
streamline now here's the other thing
hey you look like Joe Pesci when he
burned his head and home alone okay
here's the other problem I took my
manscape I've sat do a little trim oh
that's it why stop there
let's go let's hit the pubic machine the
piece I didn't know it'd be that tight
get the Philly feel on your collar 53
with very few with basically no fuse now
that's not appropriate
apparently people under 30 it's very
common for men to shape their whole body
I've always had pubes
and now manscape brought me down so meds
dude shoutout to manscape sorry right
that's what I have going on I didn't
mean to shorten things up a little bit
oh no return go back oh and then I got I
got I gotta be consistent all the way
around so crystal he looked at me and
said oh look how good that looks that
looks really good
now you should have been sporting that
for the past 10 years but you didn't
because you're a [ __ ] idiot
so so we complimented me and then it's a
nice done nice line my hair it's just
not like CIO Scouts not even I could cut
it for you
I'm not even know it's not even in there
there's like some sprigs sticking out
well I'll feed you up you know you can
paint it up yeah he owns it looks like
he's gonna Rob you though you know well
Brian looks like the worst extra from
Full Metal Jacket
[Laughter]
you know you barely see or yeah it
almost looks like a hat imprint uh-huh
but it never limb CV but your Rogen's is
thick your weren't these guys had a
couple all right it's tough yours looks
good my kids screamed at okay so Brennan
is hysterical he's laughing hysterically
because I shaved my head and he thinks
it looks terrible yeah it's good your
tongue well what did this this poor team
was a scoring team that makes you do
weird [ __ ] it makes you do Richard III I
was like I'm gonna shave my head I
didn't mean to shave my head
I meant to cut it short I was bored and
I said maybe I'll give myself a haircut
with clippers not get the long one
they weren't long enough I liked you it
wasn't bad before right yeah and now I
look a little fuzzy did my illegally
doors pigeon I pepper see I noticed my
smites my kid called said you look like
an ostrich I was like and then my
daughter screamed and ran away I was
faced iron shoes ah and screaming no I
mean no and now you're laughing super
hard let me see what I faced a little
Swan no your face homeboy it could be my
face because usually when my face is not
so on I look good meet you you have the
Rush Limbaugh yet the the Dodd up there
too huh
my aunt's an issue isn't it that's a
little strong well that's very tight huh
no one to I this I brought that I
brought my beard down a little bit and
that's the thing Oh your beard go thick
with a beard and then we might be more
know dude this is easy fix go figure
with the beard and then just grow your
hair back
see I didn't expect it to look like that
let me see the pig that's a that's an
issue that's exactly what I look like
isn't it man
I would go for a whole shave just shave
it all off and then grow it out and that
might get really bad time outgoing Dana
White yeah I mean no like it's just very
very finally I want to look like Rogan
uh hey look at me and you know I love
you sometimes you miss weddings you know
it's sometimes you miss Wednesday
it's quarantine to make you do [ __ ] up
[ __ ] Wednesday that's all it is
we're fine sometimes we grow back of
course it'll grow back eventually yeah
after we're able to go outside yeah the
meantime you didn't help me nothing
you're just like I'm gonna do it daliyah
legitimately went you look really good
he's so nice I might be longer and I
brought my beard down I took all the
hair here like night I mean you know I
thought you here look nice
yeah probably did you but you've had a
shaved head well not I see when I first
met you had a shaved head yeah thank you
shaven little older and grayer so the
problem is when you get grey with the
gray beard it's just that I guess they
top this or no it's just a little patchy
in certain areas it's a bit patchy in
certain areas so I've got a and then
there's almost three here stick in the
back like you're from like Charlie Brown
style yeah it's like sticking out the
back yeah so I'm gonna have to bring
that down to the gray is great yeah
chicks dig great dude keep that up right
girls like great girls also liked hair
so don't do that again
you got a lot of hair got a Bearden hair
I should start sporting hat no man I
don't mean to make you feel bad about
your hair hey you know though I've
always felt bad you've had good hero I
mean most your life I mean I
the last thing I'm gonna feel is bad no
I mean dude I mean do you have a
Catherine woods number no okay yeah
what's your number cat erase so we're
just clownin Brian's here Mike
Catherwood
look at the two of you go get it Mike
thick hair just take a deep good look at
it well now I'm surrounded by two guys
with very thick hair yeah that's that's
not a lie
Mike has better hair than me that's not
true you bought that pretty I like you
with the long hair too oh thanks dude I
like that you both have very good hair
are you wearing a cloth mask cuz drew
told you to UM I'm wearing a cloth
maskers I have my bum a little bit
scared I listen to CNN that I listen to
Fox I do it on YouTube follow Brian got
Corona okay I do have a little crime I
was thinking of a different virus but
yeah yeah what I noticed is that Fox is
super pro-business
you're surely if Tom Hanks didn't get
Philadelphia oh I hate this been going
on the free guy let me die over my head
I was gonna say I was gonna say don
flamenco from Mike Tyson's punch-out
yeah if we could bring a [ __ ] so give
throws wicked tongue to make oh and tell
me if that is not Brian with this you
just can't come here with a fresh new
year all right dude casual look pretty
similar yeah he's lonely Rose yeah
pretty similar is here's better I look
like Ari Shaffir Oh Ari does look like
him yeah he's a badass I'm sorry
everything all right control me
yeah please go back to paradise please
please I'm saying guys that's gonna
happen on and off too sometimes okay my
hair is a little tight my hair's a
little close to the bone we know this
right and maybe I made a mistake maybe
what did you do - I I didn't mean to
shave it I was using a shaver and I said
I'm gonna clip my hair universally and
I'm have a long you know a long bit on
the on the Clipper and then I realized I
went oh that's too deep
oh no oh boy and then that I had I had
to commit all the way we were all having
fun with it but I you look fine you look
good thank you buddy you have a very
like masculine head like there's some
people who I have buddies no it's not
worried about him like yeah it's like
sounds like a tea kettle
yeah go ahead I got tea kettle is the
tea ready
it's tea ready he just shop you got
admit there's a thing though like some
dudes the receding hairline and it's
like it looks like you look wimpy he has
like the Bruce Willis when he's younger
now listen yes well but Fox News is way
more they kind of playing it down a
little bit they're favoring sort of
let's get back to work there you go yeah
you do look look how he did it dude like
it like that almost looks better he's
straight big yeah you see that you could
be that though yeah I could be what that
guy right there but no no no not so fast
no though with a bald one of your better
looking in it like she looks good there
you're very you're better looking we got
a body too for sure
yes thank you thanks for the compliments
Brennan
the [ __ ] tea kettle over here my
buddy was a bruiser said we are it was
this is ten years ago even more
it's just shocking time it I see Brian
every day I think it's [ __ ] sick but
um did this producer said he was talking
about what a movie star is right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh
good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]